advice from chris gardner on finding
your passion
as seen in zugu101 find something that
you love
something that gets you so excited you
can't wait to get out of bed in the
morning
forget about money be happy
you have to be committed and you have to
find something that you're passionate
about
and forget about money i've learned that
money is the least
significant aspect of wealth do
something that you love
whatever you're going to do is going to
be tough enough find something that gets
you so excited that the sun
can't come up early enough in the
morning because you want to go
do your thing no matter how much money
is involved or no matter how
easy it is for you to do if you're not
happy
you're nothing more than a slave to your
talent and money
do something that makes you happy and
makes you feel good about yourself
do something that makes you feel your
work is significant and meaningful
if you just want to make money that's a
whole different trip i can't help you
with that
to learn more check out zugo 101 in the
link below
you